hi I'm Erik Bosse and the walking dead
released a new trailer for season 8 at
Comic Con and wow I feel like it's been
years since I've talked about the
walking dead so much has changed the
background is still blue whoo but we're
in a new office we got new hosts I'm
showing leg now I'm sorry that was too
sexy this trailer is 5 freakin minutes
long and there's a lot to talk about
of course all of this footage is only
from the first half of the season
probably up through Episode seven
because that's all big shot so far but
if any of my predictions in the pain
right yes possible spoilers ahead so
let's get started
I hope you got your [ __ ] in paints on
what you shouldn't pay I hope you wear
right now
because you
our amount of [ __ ] your hands
okay so the trailer opens on negan and
Gabriel it looks like Gabriel has been
captured by the Savior's and he's in
this very threatening situation and
negan scares him by saying I hope you
got your shirt and pants on now Gabriel
is confused here but I feel like special
pants that you go to the bathroom in is
negan calling back a joke that he gave
when he first met this group TP pin
Sudhir reach freely TP pants the
shooting test is your classic
heightening but remember Gabriel wasn't
there at that lineup so maybe that's why
he doesn't get it and throughout all
this we hear the sounds of Walker's
outside you can see their hands pressing
against the window but where is this
exactly
now the blinds don't really look like
the windows from the sanctuary last
season which makes me think maybe this
is Alexandria or the kingdom and the
walkers have overrun one of these
locations have some more thoughts on
that later but let's move on okay so the
trailer now uses this really cool
percussion music from the instrument the
claw they you know those things that
your music teacher had you play with
because we don't have any other musical
talent the club a is start with this
gradual build kind of sounding like a
ticking clock it actually reminds me of
a similarly gradual percussion build of
Isaac Hayes run say run you might know
that from the Kill Bill soundtrack I
just think this choice of using the claw
they as this percussion gets more and
more complex it's perfect for this whole
idea of these different tribes in the
walking dead linking together as chaos
gets more near okay then we get this
lens flare shot of Rick with his axe and
then this shot of Carol and Tara now
actually later in the trailer we see
where this is it's an overpass as they
wait for a herd of walkers to pass
underneath
I like our Tara is still wearing her
orange sunglasses remember she picked
those up on the way home from Oceanside
last season also a little missable
detail here notice Carol here she's
looking at this drawing of a flower on
the concrete wall next to her and she's
reflecting perhaps thinking about Sophia
or maybe Lizzie and mica but then she
turns away staying focused on the
mission so now that carol has finally
returned to a world of violence she
doesn't want to get too soft and then we
get coral looking through a core window
this shot is actually parallel to a shot
in the very first episode there's the
same exact framing as when coral dad
Rick looked in the car now the season 8
premiere is actually going to be the
100th episode of The Walking Dead and
that's a significant milestone actually
in the comics issue 100 was Megan's
debut so I'm thinking that they're going
to be celebrating this 100th episode
with some callbacks to the beginning of
the series in fact there's a few more
that come up throughout this trailer and
then after shots of Morgan Maggie and
Ezekiel from behind as his royal
subjects clear the way we get this
interesting look at Daryl now it looks
like there's this flaming wreckage
that's drawing Walker's but Daryl is
then no rush to get out of there this it
seems like it's part of his plan now
later in the trailer we'll see Darrell
blow a bunch of [ __ ] up and I think this
is part of a plan that he has who heard
up a bunch of Walker's kind of like what
we saw him do in season 6 and as we go
we'll see where this herd might be going
but let's move on
okay we get a look at more characters
here with shots of Michonne and Rosita
and then Enid keep you watching the
hilltop and then this shot of Aaron
looking particularly upset with blood on
his hands and face now this is total
speculation here based off of no real
evidence other than someone looking bad
but if you watch my breakdowns last
season one character who I predicted
might be meeting his maker at some point
is Erik Aaron's partner after spending a
couple seasons on the periphery of the
show
Erik started randomly getting these big
scenes then being part of these big
missions which traditionally on the
walkie did happens when a Myer character
is about to die so while it might be a
little early to start speculating on
who's going to kick the bucket in season
eight yeah Erik would be somewhere close
to the top of my list there can only be
one Erik so that's a dumb joke let me
see this shot of Tara pretending
shooting a gun kind of like a kid would
or a drug dealer trying to look tough
that's interesting because Tara has been
pretty nonviolent on the show like she
usually steps away from these big
battles and let other people do the all
the shooting so who know maybe this shot
means terrible finally starts stepping
up to take a life and then we see Dwight
reading this note and it doesn't take
much zoom in and enhancing and flipping
around to see that that says tomorrow so
my theory is that this note was written
by Daryl as a warning there's no way of
knowing for sure but we do know that
Dwight and Daryl have in the past
communicated by leaving each other these
little love notes for example in the
season finale last year Dwight wrote the
words didn't know on his solder carving
and left it for Darrell to find
basically Dwight was saying that he
didn't know that negan had to deal with
the scavengers so what does tomorrow
mean other than the obvious definition
of the day after today well judging from
Dwight's facial expression here he looks
pretty alarmed I'm guessing that this is
Daryl warning Dwight about a pending
attack from Rick's people and when will
this attack come I don't know let's look
at that note again oh my god tomorrow
and this might just lead me but I like
how this second layer of clay vase now
joins the rhythm to the
beat of the terminator score does good
so I don't know if this is intentional
or not but I just do like this parallel
of the music of a famous
post-apocalyptic world where manatee is
struggling to survive against killing
machines well I guess kind of avoiding
themselves becoming a killing machine is
now connecting in a way to this
post-apocalyptic world where humanity
struggles to survive against killing
machines while avoiding becoming the
commune in this example and then I
really like this rotating shot that
ended on this shot of a hallway with a
flickering light and then Carol barely
leaning in the frame it's just something
creepy and unnerving about it actually
reminded me a lot of the movie it
follows where the camera rotates around
as the demonic figure appears closer and
closer each time the camera makes its
revolution but also judging from this
flickering light I'm assuming this place
has backup generators and it might be
some kind of lab or Hospital and this is
another detail that reminds me of that
very first episode with Rick wandering
alone through a hospital hallway as the
lights were flickering over his head
actually there's another shot a few
seconds later in this trailer with Rick
wandering down another hallway which
might be the same location that also
reminds me of that pilot episode the
reason I bring this up is I feel like
the show has kind of gotten away from it
zombie horror roots and now it's more of
this war Western geopolitical drama with
zombies don't really have a problem with
that transition I actually think it's
just the natural consequences of what
these characters would do in this kind
of world but I would still love to see
it return a little bit more to that kind
of horror ride like when negan promised
us that we're going to [ __ ] our pants to
be nice if we ruined our clothes
sometimes because we were legitimately
creeped out okay then this trailer shows
us a close-up of this revolver this is a
tourist ultra light now we know this is
Daryl holding this you can see Norman
Reedus astara tattoo in his hand plus we
see Daryl using this gun later to blow
something up but then when he turns a
gun we see that it has 43 hash marks on
top of it presumably the number of
people killed with this gun now we've
never seen this gun before on the show
and there's no Lucille insignia on it so
my guess is that this is going to be one
of those little Walking Dead details
that pop up in the show sometimes and
hints at some side story in the universe
that we may or may not ever see but
that's something interesting worth
pointing out is that what do you three
is actually around
we're Rick's human killcount is at the
end of last season his on-screen
killcount throughout the whole series is
somewhere around 39 or 40 people of
course this gun is not Rick's gun his
gun is famously the Colt Python sale I
just like this idea that there's someone
out there who is as deadly as people
like Rick or the governor or negan but
who did it all with one weapon and is
super proud of it let's move on when I
first met it
jesus said my world was going to get a
whole lot bigger
we found that world okay in this next
next time we get this binoculars shot of
a guy who I'm pretty sure is Aaron
driving a car with these big metal
sheeting plates on the side now this is
an interesting tactic it could be used
to block gunfire to turn cars into
practical shields it kind of reminds me
of the way that they rigged up that RV
and Dawn of the Dead also a few shots
later in this section we see this same
kind of metal sheeting on a bunch of
other cars so I actually think this is
part of that plan that I mentioned
earlier hurting all the walkers to a
place and then using the cars backed up
one behind the other to form a wall
behind them and box them in okay we get
a close-up of someone using a rock to
cut himself free from ropes around his
wrist and then much later in the trailer
we see the savior Jarrett he's rubbing
his wrist as if he just freed them and
he's wearing the same shirt so I'm
pretty sure this is the same guy now you
may remember Jarrett he's that really
annoying Savior who taunted Richard last
season so it looks like this guy is
coming back and he's going to be every
bit as obnoxious and pretty sneaky too
but then we get this really cool shot of
an eye peeking out of each actually a
few other shots from the trailer helped
us piece together who this is and where
this is but you might consider it the
spoiler so if you don't want to know the
answer to that question get to
this time okay first later on we'll see
an interior angle of the shipping
container with the person who's speaking
out of the hole and check out the wound
on that person side yeah that is Rick
remember Jada's shot him inside being
the last season and you can kind of make
out the bandages also later in the
trailer there's another shot of this
same shipping container and where is it
it's in the junkyard and the background
behind Jada so putting all this together
it sounds like Rick will be captured at
some point and held by the scavengers
remember this isn't the first time rick
has been kept prisoner inside a shipping
container he was able to get out of the
one at terminus in one piece and God
willing he will do to the scavengers
what he did to those people okay as Rick
gives this rallying speech notice how
the characters are wearing different
colored armbands and all these colors
correspond to which community they live
in so like Daryl and Tara's are white
for Alexandria and then Carol and Morgan
wear red armbands for the kingdom and
Enid and later we see Maggie both wear
green armbands for the hilltop now green
might correspond to the crops that they
grow at the hilltop since it's mostly
known as a farming community and
remember red was already kind of the
kingdom's color from there tiger banners
that we saw at the end of last season
and I guess white as the color of
Alexandria makes sense in a way if you
consider black to be the color of the
Savior's like with Meghan's jacket and
Eugene's Johnny Cash getup white would
be the opposite of that color that would
make Alexandria the opposite of the
sanctuary so why are they doing it it
seems like this alliance between the
hilltop and the kingdom in Alexandria
are splitting up into smaller divisions
and that these are kind of like their
uniforms with their own insignia because
if you remember not everyone from these
three communities know each other it's
not just the characters we know from the
show there's a lot of other random
unknowns so these armbands help them
spot each other when they see each other
on the battlefield also interesting
detail here if you look in the
background of that shot of the kingdom
you can see the sanctuary so it's always
been kind of hard to tell the exact
geography of this show we don't really
know how far or close these locations
are to each other but now this is
confirmation that the sanctuary and the
kingdom are pretty close to each other
when you think about it that makes sense
for why Ezekiel would have had this
peace agreement with them like there
really is no geographical distance
between these two communities
also makes me think that the kingdom
probably has the most risk by joining
Rick and this alliance against the
Savior's like they're now in open war
with their literal next-door neighbors
all right let's move on we found each
other that bigger world is ours by right
those who use and take and kill we end
them thank you your majesty
what for being such a cool dude with
everything would be everything we've
endured everything we've risen above
everything we've become no matter what
comes next
we've won we've already won all right
after that shot of Jesus Lane this
roadside bomb which is probably one of
the ones that daryl blows up later we
get this interesting shot of these
people marching down the road they're
walking in lines and it looks like their
hands are bound kind of like a chain
gang so yeah I'm pretty sure these are
prisoners and I'm guessing that these
prisoners are saviors since it looks
like Jesus and Shoen are leading them so
my theory for this is that this could be
part of some kind of prisoner exchange
so judging from all these other shots
there's clearly going to be some battles
between the Savior's and Pete Rick and I
think there's a very good chance that in
the course of these battles one division
will end up being successful and capture
a bunch of saviors meanwhile another
division could fail and get themselves
captured and that both sides could aside
maybe the best way forward is to swap
back their POWs or maybe team rick is
trading back all of these saviors to get
Rick out of captivity I guess my point
is that the Walking Dead is now a show
about war in politics they are all part
of this world on The Walking Dead now
and I think we're going to start seeing
more of these power dynamics rather than
just you know people giving big speeches
and killing things which I've always
loved but you know if you're going to
start building society you got to start
talking to people then we get this shot
of Dwight at the sanctuary and the
Walker pit out front you can see the
metal covered walkers from Eugene
suggestions
to maintain their structural integrity
last season but if you look past those
Walker's you can almost make out Gabriel
on the other side of the fence so maybe
what's going on here is negan and the
Savior's are using Gabriel as kind of a
pond saying hey we got one of yours kind
of like they tried to do with Sasha last
season and I love this exchange between
Jerry and Ezekiel thank you your majesty
for what for being such a cool dude but
doesn't it kind of sound like Jerry is
saying these as final words right before
diving in a battle and sacrificing
himself for his king like I don't know
how both of them look pretty bloodied up
it doesn't look like they're winning
whatever battle they're in so I'm hoping
that's not the case we aren't losing
Jerry here I really love that character
but let's face it guys this is war and
it wouldn't be the Walking Dead if every
character we loved survive anyway let's
move on
[Applause]
I've been fighting sister farm kept up
now we need to win let me come with you
[Music]
you need to correct you on that point we
need to keep our faith in each other if
we can hold on to that with everything
we have the future is ours the world is
all okay so now some new music kicks in
this is prisoner's song by the Dropkick
Murphys and yeah the Dropkick Murphys
pub rock sound is kind of weird to hear
on a show like The Walking Dead like I
kind of associate that music more with
Ireland or pasta hymns but if you listen
closely the lyrics are super appropriate
yeah Rick and his people used to be
pawns in a game that they couldn't win
with negan making all the rules but now
they're dreaming of a future that they
can build for themselves and while all
these other characters flash by very
quickly we get one new face this guy but
I think there's a good chance that this
character will end up being Sadiq from
the comics so in the comics Sadiq is a
character who actually doesn't show up
until significantly after this current
all-out war with the Savior's sides
considering the show moved up other
stuff like the introduction of Oceanside
I feel like there's a very good chance
this will be City even though this
version of the character doesn't really
look anything like this to begin the
comics and it looks like Rosita and
Michonne will go on their own side
adventure in one of these episodes and
I'm wondering where is this location
like it's filled with odds and ends like
a hoarder lives here it almost looks
like that marketplace floor in the
sanctuary but I don't think they'd be
able to sneak in there undetected anyway
let me know where you think this could
be in the comment and a lot of people
have been asking about why we're seeing
Morgan and Jesus fighting it doesn't
look like Jesus particularly once to
fight Morgan here so my guess is that
Morgan is still teetering on that line
between stable Morgan and clear Morgan
remember especially after his son figure
Benjamin died last season so maybe
Morgan is going off the deep end again
and Jesus is trying to make him come
home to do let's move on over your ears
[Music]
trust the king the plan and on this day
we begin to reshape this world okay it
is great to see Carol be Carol again she
just look like she doesn't give an F
when she's shooting something with a
massive shotgun while Jerry and Henry's
asterid er my opinion carol has always
been most interesting as a character as
a kind of awkward outside dog that
struggles to adapt to domestic life now
I don't know what to shoot in here but I
have a feeling it's something that's
probably not that dangerous maybe like a
crow that's picking at these crafts
Carol would make the best scarecrow she
would just like hang a dead crow from a
post to send a message to the other
crows and then after some great shots of
Shiva in action and Jerry finally using
that battle-ax we get this line from
Aaron myself that's the plan okay again
this is all the sneak guessing but it
sounds like Aaron is hinting at this
plan that I've been alluding to all
episodes so here's what I think their
strategy is one get Daryl to herd up a
bunch of walkers with boom boom and then
lure them towards the sanctuary at that
point Aaron and the others use these
shield cars to box in the walkers from
behind and the goal of this is to trap
in the sanctuary just like Alexandria
was trapped in in the middle of season
six and then let the walkers do the rest
cut off the Savior's from the outside
world and in the kind of food or supply
line and hopefully some walkers breaking
in and destroying it from the inside out
however based on Aaron's frustration
here I'm guessing that some of the
people on Team Rick are going to get
emotional once the Savior's get in
eyesight and they're going to go rogue
and try to strike at the Savior's
directly okay I also like this shot of
Dwight here notice how the framing
places his head side-by-side with this
Walker whose face is also scarred up on
the right side it seems like the idea
here is to show the progression of
Dwight two-facedness his fear of what
could happen in if he doesn't play this
double act perfectly this overhead shot
of the junkyard shows these scavengers
again with their weird consent
circle formation but who is that
greeting Jadis in the center there it's
kind of hard to tell but that long black
hair kind of looks like Eugene's power
mullet you might have noticed that
Eugene is the only major character on
The Walking Dead that otherwise doesn't
show up anywhere in this trailer
but if this is him here I'm guessing he
would be talking to Jada to try to get
her to hand off Rick to him remember
he's inside that shipping container in
the background so that Eugene can bring
him back to negan really one of the
things I'm more interested to see in
season 8 is what happens with the
Savior's alliance with the scavengers
that was kind of a twist introduced at
the end of season 7 that they didn't
really unpack a whole lot so compared to
Alexandria and the hilltop in the
kingdom whose relationship seems pretty
tight like they're willing to jump in a
battle to protect each other's lives at
home I just don't see the saviors or the
scavengers dying for each other and I
think that lack of trust will end up
being a huge problem for them okay let's
look at that shot of Carl falling back
on some dead animal now it's hard to
tell exactly what it is even though I
don't think it's what I'm about to say
boiler alerts in case you don't want to
know some people are saying that this
could be the corpse of Sheba the tiger
and the detail people are pointing at is
that that kind of looks like a black
tiger stripe on the bottom of the frame
here but I think that's the animals eye
behind Carl there and to me that just
doesn't really look like Shiva's head my
guess is this is a deer and if so a deer
would be an interesting callback to the
deer that Carl found in season 2 and
maybe Carl just says really terrible
luck with yours and then we get this
roadside explosion blowing up a couple
cars notice that religious statue we saw
last season that the road to the
sanctuary is actually marked by a bunch
of religious statues so it seems like
people on Team Rick are using a bunch of
guerilla tactics to attack the Savior's
including this a point of view shot from
inside a car as a truck smashes into it
which reminds me a lot of the shot at
the opening of the movie Heath where a
bunch of criminals also use guerilla
tactics to ambush an armored car
and then we get this crazy awesome
chasing Ric speeds up behind this Hummer
that presumably is being driven by
saviors jumping from one car to another
guys we've never seen this kind of
high-speed stunt on The Walking Dead
AMC must been brainstorming and how to
top the action and one of those Saturday
afternoon repeat civil graders of lost
art came on and they're like yes truck
chase indeed jumping from horse to truck
indeed slamming his foot on the gas
pedal we're doing this on the walking
dead and then smash cut to the title the
walking dead and may have noticed this
is a new title in the past every new
season of The Walking Dead shows the
title looking more and more deteriorated
obviously to parallel the decay of human
flesh of a zombie but now this is the
first season where it doesn't do that it
feels like it's saying that for the
first time ever Rick and his crew are
trying to have a fresh start but also I
think that this new title is suggesting
that the Walking Dead is no longer a
show where decaying human zombies are
the biggest threat now it's about these
new societies clashing with each other
to colors white and black white the
color of Alexandria facing off against
the surrounding black of the saviors or
hell maybe in October AMC is going to
release an even more corroded title and
I'm going to look like an idiot let's
move on
[Music]
okay so some interesting stuff here for
one there's another little callback to
the very first episode where Rick wakes
up and then looks over at flowers just
like you did in that opening hospital
room but now instead of dried out and
wilted these flowers are fresh so what's
going on here some people thought that
this shot means that everything in The
Walking Dead was just a bad dream and
Rick is finally waking up for miss coma
as an old man no but the answer I think
does connect to an event in the comics
so if you haven't read the comics and
you don't want to be spoiled even though
I don't think it's a huge deal give to
this time if you don't want to know
anything about it so yes it's you've
read the comics you'll know that after
the all-out war with negan comes to an
end the comics abruptly jump forward in
time two years where Rick has aged into
old man Logan he had a big gray beard
and he walks with a cane after an injury
suffered in the war oh the surface way
of reading the scene is that Season
eight is going to conclude the savior
war and feature the time jump but I
think that would be a pretty big bummer
to drop this oiler in the first trailer
that we see for the season also as I
mentioned before production is only shot
the first seven or so episodes of season
eight at this point and everything we
see in this trailer is probably from
early in the first half of the season so
my theory for what this is is sometime
early in the season maybe the prologue
the first scene of the season we're
going to see something like this vision
of Rick in the future which would then
stage all the events in the present day
as him looking back on this war and the
people he lost but there's also another
way I could see this going I don't think
we have to interpret this image
literally max remember at the beginning
of season seven Rick experienced a
vision of everyone in Alexandria
including Abraham and Glenn and little
baby Ari all sitting around this table
now of course we knew this wasn't real
this was after Glenn and Abraham had
died this was just Rick's dream for the
future of Alexandra that we would now
never have similarly I think these shots
of old man Grimes could be a vision that
Rick has for an ideal future if he ever
manages to rid the world of negan the
opportunity to grow
what do you think this closing shot of
old man Rick means and which character
do you think is the most likely to die
in this first half of season eight I
mentioned Eric and Jerry but then again
we did just hear Morgan say I don't die
which yeah kind of sounds like the
biggest tell like Morgan might as well
have said I'm gonna live forever anyway
let me know down in the comments what
you think and if you haven't already go
back and make sure to catch up on all my
breakdown through the season 7 episode
getting some really interesting theory
and analysis that I don't think anyone
else on the youtubes really cares that
much about and share this video and
subscribe to new rockstars we're trying
to cover all the big trailers that came
out at Comic Con so keep an eye out for
those and if you feel generous you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially Tony
Stark you can hit me up on twitter at EA
vas with any thoughts that you have or
following new rock stars on Twitter at
new rockstars thanks for watching now
I'm going to go watch a bunch of other
comic-con trailers oh my god there's a
new door trailer why don't you say
anything